[Music]
this is Manama the capital of Bahrain
it's a relatively Progressive and
evolving Metropolis in the Arab world
and it's also a critical location for
the US military we could not do what we
do without them Bahrain might be a small
country in the region but it plays a
huge role when it comes to peace efforts
in the Middle East and security efforts
for countries around the world so here's
how the island Kingdom came to play an
important role on the global stage let's
start with bahrain's importance globally
I am on a U.S military ship in the
Persian Gulf right off the coast of
Bahrain and this is where the U.S Navy
is headquartered in the Middle East when
you get out on the water you start to
see oil infrastructure a reminder of why
this region is critically important to
the world Bahrain is an island nation in
the middle of the gulf nearby our oil
and gas Rich neighbors Saudi Arabia
Kuwait Iraq Iran the UAE and Qatar the
region contains an estimated 50 percent
of the world's proven oil reserves and
the street of Hormuz a few hundred miles
from bahrain's coast is considered the
world's most important choke point when
it comes to oil shipping that means
Security in this region is a vital
interest to many countries around the
world including the United States this
region literally and figuredly fuels the
world so keeping a stability and
ensuring Maritime security here is job
one for us from the Basin Bahrain vice
admiral Brad Cooper commands U.S naval
forces in the Middle East and the
biggest Naval Coalition in the world
made up of 34 countries one of the
Admiral's big initiatives building out
the world's first International Fleet of
unmanned vessels in large part to
counter Iranian activity and he says
Bahrain was the Navy's first Regional
partner in those efforts Bahrain has
also become a key player in diplomatic
efforts across the middle east in 2020
it signed on to the U.S brokered Abraham
Accords along with Israel and the United
Arab Emirates since then Morocco and
Sudan have also joined how Nations join
the path of peace and the Kingdom of
Bahrain is really one of the Pioneers in
this process the signing of the Accords
normalized relations between Israel and
some of its Regional neighbors for the
first time ever and it paved the way for
the countries to open embassies
participate in military exercises and
sign free trade agreements since the
Accords were signed bahrain's government
has welcomed visits by Israeli leaders
and even the Pope
a big reason why bahrain's participation
has been so important is the kingdom has
close ties with neighboring Saudi Arabia
which has long claimed to lead the
Muslim world
officials say Saudi okay to bahrain's
deal with Israel even though it didn't
address statehood for Palestinians and
that signaled a Monumental shift in the
region
Bahrain is also seen as a gateway to the
Saudi market for businesses which was
expected to be a big deal because the
Accords opened the door for more trade
ties between Israel and its Arab
neighbors but here's the thing ties
between Israel and Bahrain have been
slower to advance compared to relations
between Israel and the UAE and polls
show that support for the Abraham
Accords has dropped throughout the
region now government officials and
Business Leaders we've been talking to
acknowledge they have to build on the
progress that's been made in order for
everyday citizens to feel the benefits
of the Accords so how is Bahrain hoping
to reap more economic benefits from the
Abraham Accords like other Gulf
countries bahrain's economic prospects
rise and fall with oil prices but it has
built out other sectors and today
Bahrain is considered the most
Diversified economy in the region
according to the government financial
services accounts for more than 17
percent of the country's GDP slightly
more than crude petroleum and natural
gas at 16.2 percent by comparison crude
petroleum and natural gas account for
about 35 percent of Saudi Arabia's GDP
now following the Abraham Accords
Bahrain is working to attract more
investment from the U.S Israel and
Beyond as it works to continue growing
its non-oil sectors during a rare visit
to the Royal Palace which we could
photograph but not film the country's
Finance Minister Sheikh Salman binhalifa
al-halifa said Bahrain has what he calls
small country Advantage which has helped
the kingdom move quickly on economic
reforms Bahrain has also been making an
effort to boost tourism and capitalize
on being an island with water in the
Middle East to increase the number of
nights that tourists stay and the amount
of money that they spend the country has
opened a billion dollar International
Airport the gulf's largest Exhibition
Center and a new Amphitheater near its
existing Formula One Track our
population is one and a half million if
we welcome 12 14 million tourists a year
that's significant but Bahrain faces
challenges close by the country is off
Often overshadowed by its larger
neighbors who have built flashy Islands
announced futuristic cities and hosted
massive sporting events that includes
Qatar which Bahrain has icy relations
with and perhaps most critically
neighboring Saudi Arabia has begun to
liberalize allowing music festivals
movies and possibly even wine bars
Bahrain in Saudi are linked by this
Causeway which is just 15 miles long
it's bahrain's only land connection to
the outside world and currently a
majority of bahrain's tourists come from
Saudi to enjoy things that aren't
allowed back home like alcohol as Saudi
liberalizes will they still be coming to
Bahrain we're confident that growth and
development is Saudi is a benefit for
all of us in this region what really
happens is the pie becomes bigger and
everybody's individual slice of the pie
continues to get bigger
foreign